e
e e
good
morning it being 10: a.m.
like to call the meeting of Public Works
and highways to
order and we're going to start with
House Bill
375 and
recognize main sponsor representative
Maguire you're on sir thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Dan Maguire I
represent the town of Epsom so this bill
um just started as an idea that came to
me when I saw how capable modern ATVs
are and how really how expensive I mean
some of them are $20,000 up so they're
almost standard Vehicles right I mean
and um they essentially all come with
headlights and brake lights and so on um
and and it seemed to me that it would
sort of enhance um tourism if people
were allowed to use them not just
off-road but also onroad in some cases
right so they can um go from their
perhaps rental property to restaurants
and stores and things like that and so I
started looking into the situation it
turns out there's lots of other people
who were sort of there with that idea
way way ahead of me and I discovered
that this is already implemented in um
the city of Berlin and also the town of
colbrook and Poss possibly others that I
don't know of but but it's it is
something that I've heard from uh the
representatives from Berlin that it's
been a big boost to their Town's economy
that that um uh they have designated uh
town roads as being and and I believe
some state roads as being capable of uh
people driving their ATVs into town and
so on and um it's caused a lot more um
tourism in their area um more people
going to restaurants all this sort of
stuff so they're they're very positive
about it and so I thought that I would
put in the bill just to I mean there's
currently nothing in law as far as I can
tell that allows it or disallows it or
so on or gives it any structure so I
thought I put in the bill so that our
law would have kind of a you know ground
rules of how this is to be done um uh
and and certain structure to it that
towns can adopt it's all none of this is
mandatory it's just that if you want to
allow ATVs to to be used on your roads
this is the structure you would you
would follow and so um I'm not wetted to
any of the details in it if you think
I'm gone over or under in some area and
want to change things great you know
this is really not you know I don't
often put in bills in this area so you
know my knowledge of it is is not that
broad but um let me point out
specifically what it does so it
basically allows a municipality to
designate certain uh Section Road
segments as as being you uh available
for ATV travel and it um would require
them to to make a map um both available
at town office and online of those areas
it allows them if they want to to put up
signs uh showing it it allows them to
designate those um areas as having a
certain seasonality so you know if you
only want to do it in summer or only in
Winter or not in mud season or whatever
you can do you can do that um it uh
requires that those sections of Road the
way this is written it has a maximum
speed limit of 40 m an hour now I have
in the back of my mind that I intended
30 miles an hour so I don't remember I
don't remember what Berlin actually does
I think it might be 30 and not 40 but uh
maybe you'll you'll find out about that
but but anyways it's it's only for roads
up to some speed limit you could change
that if you wanted to and um the other
thing it puts some restrictions on
ATVs themselves and the and the most um
the one you might want to think about is
directional signals so so they have to
have
um uh they would have to have headlights
tail lights brake lights I think that's
already standard in the law um it adds
here a horn emergency flashers and
directional signals and my understanding
is most are not manufactured with
directional signals but those are an
add-on that people can get if they want
to so I just thought for safety if
you're driving these at night that's an
important feature you might think
otherwise so that that's the part that
might be controversial um but other than
that I'm I'm happy to answer
questions thank you representative
McGuire representative
fauler thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for taking
questions I
drive a uh side by side which is
registered for travel on the uh on the
roadways as an agricultural vehicle but
it has different requirements and there
was a state state law that allows allows
that but uh doesn't include horns
directional signals or flashers does
require lights requires
mirrors and requires
a slow vehicle triangle to you mounted
on the back
so is there an attempt to
um I wonder if there's a conflict
between one set of regulations for one
vehicle looks very much like your your
off-road
vehicles um and whether you
really whether you considered the um
that particular conflict yes thank you
for the question my my intention is not
to
be to get in the way of any existing use
right so you talked about agricultural
so this is intended mostly to be to be
on top of whatever people use the road
for and the ways they use the road and
um be more again for tourism or
occasional use and and that kind of
thing um so I don't think there's
necessarily a conflict because if you
already have your agricultural plate and
your you know other requirements and
you're following those I don't think
this precludes that in any
way I'm sorry any other
questions representative bogert thank
you Mr chairman
um along with the ATVs that are in
modern day with this requirement uh golf
carts seem to also be uh heading towards
that way we're allow to cities and stuff
or communities and stuff are allowing
golf carts to be driven around like a
car and they have all the same function
and stuff would that also be something
that is thought of I'm yes thank you for
your question so I mean a golf cart is
sort of a summer only vehicle right so
um I don't know it's quite
as quite as likely to be wanted to be
used in New Hampshire as ATVs right um
but I I guess it would depend there's
some there's a certain section of law
here um RSA
25-a
colon4 which has specifications for what
these kind of vehicles have and so I
guess if a golf cart met that RSA then
yes it would be
included thank you
excuse me uh representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman so on on
line six on the bill the question I have
is um I'm not un not sure what this
exemption portion is here in line six
where it says municipalities and the
Bureau of trails are exempt from the
permitting process and requirements of
21583 regarding Bridge or connector on a
portion of the highway designated TV TR
so can you clarify that for me thank you
thank you for the question and I'm I
don't think I can
um I saw somebody from Bureau of trails
here who might be able to answer that
better um that's something the drafter
put in and found so I I'd be happy to
wait till he gets up and speaks thank
you thank you any other
questions saying none thank you
representative thank you Mr chairman my
committee is meeting now so I'm afraid
I representative cre
[Music]
okay only if speaking on the bill not
speaking on said Bill I'm sorry I
apologize no no we shouldn't have filled
out the pink
card representative St
Clair
also not don't have to fill out a pink
card
the that's good these are not
good I apologize to the committee newbie
error no
no Alan Hennessy please
NHD hi good morning for the record uh my
name is alen hansom I'm the state
maintenance engineer for the Hampshire
Department of
Transportation um we have a a couple of
um portions of the bill that that cause
questions for for our agency um the
first being the question that
representative Brown posed regarding um
municipalities and Bureau of Trail has
been exempt from the permitting process
um the permitting process is what we use
in state agencies to authoriz to
interact with with applicants and
interact and
uh um issue the authorization for the
use if that is the end product of it um
to uh to
exempt um entities from the pering
process kind of
subverts what the department of TR
Transportation does to uh to regulate
the highway so we question how that
might work
um um
in
determining what happens and and uh um
what the end result might be from from
the request uh to use a certain section
of Road um so we would we would request
that that be Revisited um and and the
other comment that that we would offer
is that we recommend the uh that they
follow the the requirements of RSA 215
A6 um 9 which
includes uh the requirement for public
hearing um signage at the limits of the
of the segments designated to um alert
Road uses that they can expect ATV
travel on the road as well as alert the
ATV users of where they can can start
using the road and and end using the
road um and uh imposing requirements on
the Riders to uh to follow the
regulations
um um that being said I think I uh open
the questions
any
questions representative
Malone thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so um can do
you have any data on ATV uh safety in
New Hampshire for for example just
what's in particularly maybe on the
rates of accidents that ATVs have I I
don't I I don't I don't do ATVs I do
Highway Maintenance so I'm not I'm not
familiar with uh
with what um with a question that you're
asking may I
follow please thank you so do you know
where we to get that data um the the uh
enforcement agencies for ATV use which
would be um State Police and fishing
game I think would be better suited to
to answer thank you very
much thank you representative alone
uh is gentleman filling out a pink card
to speak okay thank
you sounds like you have a lot of
question
question I'm sorry representative vurt
you're over here in my blind
spot thank you Mr chairman uh I was just
curious if you could clarify because uh
when you were speaking to that uh
section one um and I didn't know if I
quite understood what you were trying to
make a point at for your recommendation
for that
section sure thank you um well as
written it says that the municip
municipalities and Bureau of trails are
exempt from the permitting Pro per
permitting process sorry um regarding
Bridge or connectors along the portion
of the highway so the the connector is a
trail along the along the
roadside if they're exempt from the
pering process what
determines um where where the where the
travel is allowed um how are we alerted
to it do we have an opportunity to
review and approve it um this this says
that you know for instance the town can
can determine a section of road to be
open for ATV use but we're we're out of
the picture so we not being involved in
a permitting process
um we're we're not aware of um the
goings on and who's asking for what so I
I don't know what I don't know what that
what that means how how they would
expect it to to operate so
followup thank you Mr chairman so let's
say an expressway went through a town
sometimes they do and uh are you
indicating that maybe not being able to
be have a uh seat at the table they
could allow ATVs all of a sudden to be
on an expressway for a short period of
time and then come back off at at at
Will based on the municipality only
saying that they can do that I I believe
that might be the result of this we we
don't
know um some some towns have interstate
highway main throw fairs and back roads
and um it's not
clear
um what uh what the guidelines would be
where it would be allowed
so thank you any further
questions representative
rockmore thank you Mr chairman um so
representative Maguire told us that the
towns of burlin and cber had also had
already opened up some of their roads to
ATVs so am I to understand that that
those towns went through a permitting
process with do before they did so yeah
there was a coordinated effort between U
between the OHV groups regulate
regulatories agencies and
do thank you any further
questions representative jurus thank you
thank you Mr chairman and so would it be
my understanding uh like you talk about
Berlin and gorm that you need the
necessary signage where the sign would
say where you can get on and where you
could get off the uh State
Road yes on on the designated routes up
in the North Country there is a sign
that says um ATV use allowed and I think
on the far end of it there's a End ATV
use or signs to that effect so they
there's a sign at either end of the of
the allowed section to alert you know
operators not to continue on where
they're going
follow quick followup thank you Mr
chairman uh so in this case in the way
the Bill's
written uh the town would pay for the
signage but the permitting process
through the state wouldn't be able
to um Define what you just said where
you can access and then where you can
depart the particular State
Road I'm not sure I understand the
question but to today there there's
permitting process cesses for uh many
activities in a right away and there's
um to Define you know the the the use of
the driveway of the of the trench permit
for water sewer lines or something like
that that there would be an ability to
to have designated roots and include the
the signage where required that's part
of it today if you look in BR and gorm
this the signs are there
so I'm not sure that that
one one uh prohibits the other from
happening so okay thank
you seeing no further questions thank
you uh and I'd like to call on Captain
Michael is that Eastman East Eastman of
fishing game
please thank you Mr chairman and the
members of the committee I uh didn't
intend to testify today just U because
because uh my Colonel had asked me just
to come in and sign in um but it seems
that you have a lot of questions um
about this so um I will Sor to say that
my commission did oppose uh this bill uh
just kind of the way that it's written
um and nothing not speaking to
representative Maguire or Senator Pearl
um you know I think they are good
intentioned in in this bill and uh
submitting this bill um really at this
time uh there are laws it's that so 250
15 A6 says that you need to have
permission or you cannot operate on
highways class one 3A highways public WS
you cannot operate um uh at oh hrvs um
one issue with the bill is that uh it's
speaks about ATVs which there are
definitions of so ohvs encompasses
snowmobiles uh ATVs
utvs um and so there's
a difference between those those
different Vehicles an ATV would be uh
basically what you would what we would
consider the four-wheeler that were the
used to the original ones with the Honda
were the three-wheelers and those are
right on top motorcycle style um if you
will Vehicles a UTV is totally different
that's what you're going to see I think
that's what uh representative fauler was
speaking about um and that uh they you
get inside them ride them they're more
like a dune buggy esque type of vehicle
so the definition is very you know very
different between or the vehicle by
definition makes it very different uh
right now um any town or any
municipality can open up their roads uh
to ATV UTV o HRV use um and that can be
done um in in you know at town meeting
or or through the selectman whatever the
case may be um and uh there are laws
that go along with that saying that they
have to consider you know what what the
law enforcement for that or the law
enforcement for that town or the lack
thereof is responsible for you know if
if there's a complaint then the local
police department is going to cover that
complaint um so uh you know certainly
they can do that now um there's also a
law that says that towns um within and
this changed probably 15 years ago uh
that says that in Coos County Grafton
County and a portion of actually
Hillsboro um there are State highways
that are open to ohrv use um and there's
actually another bill currently um that
just I just believed it received in a
house number believe it's
367 is that right
Rich um believe it's 367 that speaks
about extending those those counties um
for use for ohrv use um just to speak on
a couple of the questions that I heard
um as far as oh the accidents uh we
retain our fishing game retains
accidents there about 60 if you will
throughout the state snowmobile and oh
HRV um and the the basic the largest
cont contributing factor to that is uh
speed and in experience that's the and
then I think this year like careless and
Reckless kind of came in there as one of
the top three um any anything that
occurs or any accd that occur on the
roads are covered by either that
municipality's police department or the
state police um because we don't cover
accidents on roadways we cover the ones
that happen out in the woods on the
trails now certainly in absence you know
if they're if State Police is covering a
domestic in Lancaster and can't get to
cover an ohrv accent on you know 113 and
in Berlin we will help them obviously um
so um in as far as the uh I heard the
question about the um
golf carts golf carts are not defined as
an O HRV or an ATV so they would not
fall on this um there is actually a u a
Department of Motor Vehicle and I can't
speak too much to it but I do know that
there is a slow moving vehicle plate
that people can get for um you know for
uh golf carts uh for instance you know
if they live within a community and they
can drive their golf cart down to the
beach they can get that plate and there
are a lot of restrictions that go along
with that as well uh
and so but that's for Department of
Motor Vehicle really to speak to um as
far as the special commercial plates
which representative F was speaking
about um that is a plate for agriculture
and light industrial use um so that is
once again through Department of Motor
Vehicle and there are restrictions on
that there's as he said the the speed
limit restrictions um agriculturally you
can only go 10 miles from the from the
farm or wherever you know uh that
agricultural
businesses going on and then light
industrial is 2 miles um and I always
explain it it's like you know if FW web
had a uh you know a storage area two
miles down the road and they want to
take an ATV to go get plumbing supplies
and bring them back to the main store
that would be some that would be a use
that they could use it for or you know
anything any other maybe Landscaping use
or something like that that's where we
generally see them so um
so those were the questions I heard and
certainly I'm I'm here if there's any
other
questions Point privilege Captain asan
thank you first of all because that took
care of all the questions I had that I
was jotting down as we were going over
here that hadn't been asked yet and I
think the most important thing that I
heard out of your testimony was the fact
that we already do have u a a position a
procedure in place to get most of this
done already that this bill is trying to
cover having said that representative
fauler thank you again I had a couple
questions about the vehicles uh that are
mentioned in the in the bill here uh one
is because I think you might be familiar
with it they indicate the vehicle should
be capable of going 40 miles an hour I
I'm not sure it's safe to drive with
ohrv tires on a paved roadway at that
speed I never do and do most of these
actually come with directional signals
uh flashers and other the the other
items here or is that is
that is that is that part of what a know
normal off-road vehicle has I can speak
to that uh it really all depends what
you are looking for and what you pay for
if you walk into any ohrv store and say
I want a side by side you know so I can
go ride in Jericho State Park you're
going to get the one that has uh you
know ATV tires for off-road use now
certainly um there are different types
of utvs out there you know you can go to
the Tractor any tractor store and buy
like a gator style um that does come
with different you know break breaks
with directionals you can get really
whatever you want and there's a lot of
aftermarket stuff out there as well um
but at the end of the day um with all
that said when you and we're not a title
state for ATVs or utvs or any ohrv but
at the end of the day when they get that
title in hand it says off off Highway
recreational vehicle uh no matter what
you know what you put on
it uh thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you for uh agreeing to answer some
questions uh given that we already have
the permitting process and it's managed
apparently it's managed by Dot and
working well uh and particularly if you
look at section two of the bill it seeks
to preempt the existing permitting
statutes uh in your opinion does this
bill add any value to the process that's
already in
place I could say that certainly
Department of Transportation does have a
perming process in those areas where
it's allowed they do a lot of like Road
Crossings for snowmobile trails um so
the perming process for instance an
example I can give you is uh in gorum um
there is a section of Route 16 portions
of Route 16 in in Coos County are open
but there's a section from what is now
moms used to be Shaws um to just before
you get into town in Berlin that's
closed on that section and the reason
for that is because there's a large
intersection uh which houses Walmart and
um and it is quite busy and uh so for
instance that small section is closed
and there are other businesses within
there besides Walmart small strip malls
above that um so it's really it's just
so in that permitting process yes 16 you
can operate on it and you can go to moms
and leave moms and and buy whatever you
want but um if you go beyond that it is
closed just because it is so busy in the
interaction with those smaller vehicles
and understand these vehicles are
they're not you know they might be the
size of a you know a Toyota Yus but
they're not through the same crash um
you know specifics that that toyot ARS
would have over the Polaris Razor
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman can you just expand a little
bit captain on the uh issues that the
commission had why they're against this
Bill thank you uh well for one I already
stated was the ATV definition that was
one that I had brought to them um the
other is is that in the way that I read
it and it's potentially them reading it
wrong but the way that I saw it was that
a municipality could um say yes we want
to have roads we want to open up roads
within our town and we want to open up
State highways um and in question that
comes to my mind is there different
there's different uh funding mechanisms
there so obviously town roads are taken
care of through town funds whereas state
roads are taken care of and I I'm
probably speaking out of turn here and
uh General can speak much better on that
but um so for instance you know this
time of year the town is plowing the
town roads and Dot is plowing the state
roads so once again where does that come
into that that funding mechanism and and
now you have you know low pressure tires
tearing up sides of roads and pavement
and how do you pay for that so that it
just brings some questions to my mind on
on that side of it as far as funding so
that's really the two things that I
presented to the to the commission and
why they had issue with
it followup please uh so Captain if you
if I understand right if if the
permitting process was place that was
kind of uh exempt in this initially if
that was in place you wouldn't object to
the bill as it's indicated if we cleared
up the language on ATV versus
OHV once again like I said I I think
that uh representative Maguire and
Senator Pearl are good intentioned on
this bill but I think that um you know
there are other bills out there that
kind of uses the same mechanisms that
we're using right now um that do is
using Bureau Trail are using um that
would be better to to continue on with
with those review processes that are
already in place thank
you I'm
sorry representative Lewis thank you Mr
chairman Captain there was one thing I
just real quick the uh you you gave a an
approximate number of uh accidents that
fishing games responded to none of those
were uh particular they would have been
all on Trails or is that those accidents
are referring to also on on roads and
and I had a follow up to that after the
I can't say that all of those I mean the
majority of them are on Trails um
because that's really what we would keep
those acents for now if um you know the
local police department or uh where it
happens on a road would they would do it
under Ro a i they believe it's a DS smv
form which is the the traditional motor
vehicle accident form um so because they
would have to treat it as a motor
vehicle so you wouldn't you wouldn't
have any record of of what they're
responding to if they were involved with
an ohrv if a town municipality responded
to that the fishing game doesn't track
that we do not sometimes they send them
to us and sometimes they don't thank you
thank you any other further questions
seeing none thank you very much Captain
thank you uh next I'd like to hear our
final speaker uh Craig reny
please step up and identify
yourself good morning uh my name is
Craig reny I'm the chief of the Bureau
of trails at the Department of Natural
and cultural resources and I was here
this morning to help answer some
questions um so I did fill out a card so
I could just speak briefly the the
permit process that's and by the way
we're not taking a position on the bill
but I just wanted to clarify a few
things um the permit process that was um
questioned earlier by representative
Brown so that process that we go through
Bureau trails and Dot now works very
well we uh you know we we look for you
know we permit Highway Crossings and
connectors with do so as ohrv trails are
crossing highways or there's on Highway
connectors they submit them to Bureau
Trails we review them and then we submit
them to do because we depend on their
expertise their engineering expertise to
make sure it's safe to Cross or use you
know Highway rways and stuff for for our
Trail connections so that's an important
part of that process um if if you will
and as Captain e Eastman mentioned
there's a um there's another bill
upcoming in the rr&d committee that is
adding five counties to on Highway use
for ohvs I think this bill uh is pointed
out stating ATVs but the the other house
bill is ohvs which includes utvs side by
sides as well as as well as ATVs U but
I'm happy to answer any questions you
may
have thank you
is that a you want to ask a question I
have a question
Mr
recognize boy thank you Mr chairman and
Mr reny thank you very much for taking
my question y simply put do you know in
your experience how long does the
process
take um it can take a few it can take a
few months so the the first part when a
say an oav Club comes to us or or even a
municipality and say Hey you know we
want to have a highway Crossing or
connector here we go out with our
District supervisor and and look at the
Crossing you know with the the person
requesting whether it's the club or or
municipality check it out make sure it's
a it's a good area to connect the trail
Network and then we we have actually an
application form that goes to dot for
review and then they'll often meet with
us on site as well and we'll look at the
safety aspects so line of sight you know
for highway traffic the what's the
vehicle speed on the highway um you know
what are the slopes approaching the
highway on the shoulders all those
safety things should be considered when
you're crossing a highway or getting on
a highway
system does that answer your question
few months it takes a few months
generally speaking um I I will say uh to
to Do's credit um on the ohrv side they
created a GIS mapping tool a few years
ago to kind of map out where all the
ohrv highway Crossing connector permits
are so both agency can look at that look
at that tool and see where the crossings
are see where there's pending
applications see where some have been
approved or denied and so we both have
access as agencies to look at that
information and it's to help you know
get us better aligned to get those
reviewed and approved in a timely manner
uh so that tool is that mapping tool is
working pretty good so you know that's a
benefit to both agencies I would say
okay thank you for your answer thank you
Mr chairman yeah any further questions
for Mr
rener representative
bogert uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
question
um after listening to your testimony and
and that of do is there anything that
this bill brings to the table that
current
law doesn't have so right now for on
Highway use um for oh hrvs in law now
it's Grafton and Coos counties and um
and then there's some other
um specific areas called out in the law
like there's a section um there's a
highway Crossing on Route 114 that's
mentioned in the section of Law and
there's few others in Hillsboro County
but um this opens up the whole state uh
to ohvs and I think again there's an
existing process for and I guess maybe I
don't want to confuse the issue but
there really is two issues for ohrv use
on highways there's Crossing and
connectors which is one part of the
statute and other stat part of the
statute where I mentioned Grafton and
cost County that's on Highway use so
there's two different parts of 215a that
you're looking at
here
followup uh thank you so you indicated
that this bill opens it up across the
state and it also allows on Highway
use across the state correct and and it
doesn't specify what types of Highways
and byways and expressways correct and
those other sections of Statute call out
highways one class one through three or
4 through six in the existing statute
now so those are all um
identified one follow up thank you
um so the current laws that there to
certain counties as one aspect of it is
and it was indicated that they're
looking there's already a a house bill
somewhere that's looking to expand that
but maintain the current permitting
processes and the current language
wouldn't change and stuff so all the
Safeguard the guard rails that are in
place would remain is just adding new
counties to the list correct that's my
understanding the bill it doesn't change
any of the permit procedes or review
that we normally go
through thank you any other further
questions from Mr
rener representative
Melvin does this exclude uh dir
bikes um ohvs does not include dirt
bikes Captain Eastman is that correct
yeah would include dirt bikes but not
under the ATV not under the ATV
definition yeah
seeing no further questions thank you
very much Mr
rener thank you and at this time I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
375 e
one second
please we miss
just I'm missing some of the handouts
here on this these bills as as it's
listed
there they were passed out last week and
I'm sure somebody picked yours up by
accident
so um
okay good thank
you is there anybody else missing any of
these
handouts you are too um we we'll take a
brief five minute recess if you guys
want to get uh your missing bills from
uh Karen tell you she needs at least two
copies
right yeah inter already place so I
don't know I question now whether we
need
e
e e
at this point in time I'd like to call
the I'd like to declare the public
hearing for House Bill 181
open and rep recognize representative
P your
answer good morning CH Mr chairman and
the members of the committee I'm
representative Mark PR from Hillsboro 15
which is Manchester Ward 8 uh today I
bring you Bill
181 uh reference to the opticom system
uh which is what emergency vehicles use
to change the the traffic lights to our
favor so we can get through them without
crashing into people or people crashing
into us either usually them crashing
into us um but over the years we've
noticed that on the state intersections
they haven't been working so I'm
springing this to see if we can't get
them uh repaired and maintained uh
because I'm not show what happened they
used to do a really great job and then
and the problem with that
is this one works the other one was
working yesterday but now it's not
working we and then we're looking for
the and they're not working for us and
um so it's kind of confusing for us
whether they're going to work today or
not or is this one working but the other
one doesn't so we're just trying to get
them maintained and uh that's really all
I have I know there's money involved and
uh but that's all I have any
questions do we have yes we do
representative
Bogart thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question um this uh system that you're
looking to have do start to take care of
who installs this equipment initially
and who purchased it
initially as far as I know the dot
bought it and installed
it the other question is representative
fauler
uh you basically describe what kind of
vehicles you use it is it mostly
Municipal Vehicles fire police fire
police
ambulances so do any state Vehicles use
the Opticon and is
the uh not the level that we use as far
as I understand so uh Fire Marshall
might be using it or State Police might
be using
it ref follow up at follow up please so
uh right now the municipality typically
would be maintaining some parts of the
system the ones that are on their own
correct and they have the
expertise to maintain it yes so we're
really talking about who pays for that
rather than so how it gets done
initially when the system came out and
this was a long time ago so I may have
some of the may be fuzzy for me on some
of the exact facts and I'm sure the
people behind me have them um the system
came out one once you declared your city
or whatever a opticom city every
intersection had to have it and if it
was in a municipality on a Municipal
Road the municipality was charged with
maintaining and keeping that system
up and I also knew that the state had
the same deal if they put them in and
and they were putting them in it was
their responsibility to maintain them
that's what I
understood thank you any other further
questions yes representative Brown thank
you Mr chairman so what your concern is
is basically that on the state roads
there's a problem with the maintenance Z
correct so what would be wrong with just
ensuring that the municipalities do
their part and that the state roads are
taken over and maintained by the
state so absolutely the municipalities
do their part they
maintain their system were the ones that
are being neglected are the state ones
as far as I at least in my area that I'm
functioning in although I noticed one of
them got fixed the other day so follow
chair thank you um
so is there a a a maintenance schedule
like I have a security system in my home
my security company does a standard test
monthly to make sure that my system's
working properly is there a program for
that in the municipalities or the State
you don't know in the municipalities if
we notice one I used to work for the
city of Nashville on the fire department
if we notice one wasn't working we got
back to the station we called the
highway
department and it was
fixed I used to be on the fire
department too and I'd be concerned if
there were no regular testing and then
we get out there and we're going to an
intersection we could potentially have
an accident we're ready to go through
that so all right thank you I I think
any other further questions pertaining
to that might be held for DOT when it's
their opportunity to speak uh if there
are no other further questions for
um representative Edgar thank you Mr
chairman um I know there's different
words to the effect of some of this but
just to clarify it again to me the part
of the system that is on the vehicles
themselves is installed and maintained
by who by us the municipality that put
it on their vehicle okay so you
all of it okay yep on your own vehicles
thank you yep thank
you thank you
Mr next call on Leo
leeon
barones from the
do please introduce yourself welcome to
Public Works introduce yourself please
yes thank you Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak to you my name is Lee bonis I
am the administrator of the Bureau of
traffic at dot also the state traffic
engineer among other things the Bureau
of traffic is responsible for the design
operation and maintenance of traffic
signals on state maintained roadways uh
the department does not take a position
on this bill but I'm here to provide
some basic information and to answer any
questions um I have some some notes here
to kind of go through what preemption
systems are and how they work um and uh
the current situation if you if you may
I'll proceed with that please okay uh
traffic signal preemption systems that's
more of the generic term than opticom uh
they're technology that interrupt the
normal traffic signal cycle to provide a
traffic signal indication that's
favorable to the user and then
transitions the signal back to a normal
cycle I think many of us have seen them
work here in conquer and other other
cities uh generally these are uh
installed for emergency vehicles that's
what we see predominantly but they can
also be used in other cases such as for
Transit priority uh for maintenance and
also for
railroads uh when railroads are in close
proximity to a traffic
signal uh the components of the system
are the initiator which is usually
mounted on a vehicle or some other
location like a fire station which
initiates the uh call for a preemption
uh there's detectors that receive that
signal and then there's preemption
circuitry within the traffic signal
cabinet that interpret those um messages
from the initiator and Trigger uh the
change in the traffic signal
controller uh there are uh a couple of
different technologies that are used uh
the one we're talking about here is an
optical technology uh the two common
brands are opticom uh as well as Tomar
uh opticom is kind of the generic or has
become the the name kind of like Kleenex
is for tissue um so uh not all systems
are opticom um but they may be Optical
actuated um the optical technology is a
mature technology uh as you heard it
it's been around for a long time um I
like to use the term mature instead of
old um so but it is um it it continues
to evolve um the there are challenges
with with that technology like many
other
Technologies um there's issues of um
false calls uh there's um issues with a
the detection can only be received
within a short distance and it doesn't
it takes too long to cycle through the
uh traffic signal phases to get to a a
green for the approaching vehicle um
generally fire apparatus which move a
little slower than uh police cars May um
T it tends to work better for the fire
apparatus than police cars they may
still arrive at an intersection see a
red light um there's uh there are other
technologies that are used for Signal
preemption these can include radio
transponders uh GPS technology that
either goes to um local antennas or up
to the cloud um some of the U some
cities and towns uh are employing the
alternative Technologies at this point
um the existing landscape uh under
current policy and practice traffic
signals on state highways host emergency
preemption systems as specified by the
respective municipality the choice of
the technology is determined by the
municipality to ensure compatibility
between the vehicle amounted initiators
and the system at the traffic signal uh
for initial
installations um such as a brand new
traffic signal the dot includes uh a
Tomar or opticom uh traffic signal
preemption system as part of the package
that's installed um because it's
certainly more economical to install it
all at once uh this includes the um
receivers which are up on the Mast arms
near the traffic signal displays uh as
well as as the circuitry inside the
traffic signal cabinet um however
subsequent repair and maintenance of the
systems testing um falls to the
responsibility of the
municipality um in practice uh the use
and investment uh by municipalities and
Signal preemption varies widely across
the towns in the state some towns don't
need it some don't use it uh some have
one signal in town uh
um and they you know not participate and
then other locations city of conquer
Manchester Nashua which have their own
traffic signal um Crews for their o for
their municipally owned signals um
maintain their systems um and make full
use of the capabilities of these systems
so we see a wide range across the
state uh I believe Nashua has just
transitioned to a alternative technology
using um GPS and um transponders that
communicate to to the cloud and uh that
allow the system to understand where all
the vehicles are and how they're
approaching different intersections and
it's uh much more of a smart intelligent
system um than the than the opticom
which is um you know essentially uh
pushing a button saying I want to come
through this this
intersection
um so as I said it has been policy since
these have been in use that the uh
municipalities are responsible for
maintenance of the systems uh the
department does assist municipalities
where they can um however when it comes
to purchasing equipment or replacement
parts um we we work with the
municipality for to get that from them
uh and have things
installed um the um where we can uh as
as available we do provide assistance
with troubleshooting and getting systems
back back in line like I said some
municipalities have a uh full traffic
signal uh work crew that is very
familiar with these systems other
municipalities do not and rely just on
their their highway road agent in some
cases uh in which case we need to
provide more more expertise to
assist um so the proposed legislation
specifies the Department of
Transportation would become responsible
for the maintenance of the pr uh traffic
signal preemption systems um I think the
intended benefit is uh consistent
performance and maintenance of
preemption systems um we prepared a
fiscal note uh which has been included
um some of the key assumptions in that
is that we are looking looking at an
optical only system uh that we're not um
endeavoring to use the higher
intelligence systems because of the
additional cost and in many cases uh is
not uh is not of value to the particular
locations um the we have excluded uh any
work on the vehicle emitters those are
the strobes that are mounted on the
emergency vehicles there's a wide
variety of mountings and types and uh
how they're powered and that is not our
business to
be um mucking around underneath the
dashboard of a fire apparatus or police
vehicles um so that was not included in
our in our fiscal note um this would
create a very significant expansion of
workload um we have four traffic signal
Crews to serve the the entire State um
we estimate that we would need at least
one more crew of two plus a vehicle uh
to raise raise us up to five Crews uh
because of the workload that would be
involved in in maintaining these systems
and we've also assumed that this would
only apply to signals owned and
maintained by the by the state not the
municipal um signals so in summary the
advantages uh that I that I see are
Consolidated responsibility it would
involve U would allow for centralized
training to a limited number of people
um so that that each municipality didn't
have to have uh someone knowledgeable or
hire a contractor to to do the work uh
it would help provide some consistent uh
level of Maintenance of the systems um
and that would be an improvement for
many communities um who either don't or
are unable to maintain their systems
however it would also probably lower the
uh you know the attention in some
municipalities where uh they have the
capability and interest uh in that
investment um and it basically brings
everybody to a Level Playing Field uh
some of the drawbacks of the systems um
there are there will still remain
operational challenges um these systems
are um can be Troublesome uh and it
takes quite a quite a bit of effort to
get these optimize to work um you think
about it you're you're transmitting a
flash ing uh light or a uh flashing Al
um uh infrared uh emitter at a point way
down the at the end of the block on this
little thing that sits up on top of a
intersection um You've Got Dirt you've
got we we see a lot of spider nests that
get into these uh detectors uh that
block those signals you've got potential
wire disconnections uh issues with the
card um there's a lot of things that can
that can go wrong with these systems uh
so I don't want anyone to have um the
illusion that um magically everything is
going to work uh every time all the time
um this will another drawback is the
amount of workload that this will add as
well as the potential liability for the
State uh if if the uh a crash occurs and
there's question of whether the um the
uh preemption system was operating
properly uh we already have liability
with maintaining the traffic signals
themselves uh this com you know adds
adds an additional level to that um the
response to concerns will be prioritized
at a Statewide level um essentially it's
taking it out of local control uh you
know the um you know the town of
Smithville um may have someone who has a
great deal of interest in there opticom
and would jump on any issues immediately
um if it's at the state level we have to
assess uh and prioritize our work uh to
deal with traffic signals throughout the
state and so that may not get the
attention that the town of smithmill
might be interested in now I hope that's
a fictitious town I didn't mean to imply
any particular Town um one approach may
not work for all municipalities as I as
I mentioned Nashua has uh taken on a a
an intelligence system um that has many
many capabilities that work work very
well for them um that is not something
that we would necessarily be able to
provide um for every municipality that
that wants such a system um the
municipal signals would not be part of
this effort so there could still be um
gaps in maintenance depending on how
thorough the municipality is with with
work on their own signals and also the
municipalities and responder agencies
would still be responsible for their um
equipment on their
vehicles so I'll stop there and I'll
take questions Mr chairman thank you Mr
Bron before I recognize anybody else I
just want to uh make sure I heard this
correctly that the current system right
now is that after the municipality
decides that they're going to install
this system that they maintain it
whether it's on a state road or not
because it's in their municipality they
may maintain it right now that's the
current procedure so if anything goes
wrong so
you basically don't maintain any of
these right now on state roads correct
we we are not responsible we do assist
when requested by towns um some are very
capable and don't need our assistance
others um others do okay thank you
representative clud here okay thank you
Mr chairman a question in the bill uh
Roman numeral 2
on lines 11 through 13 it says the
Department of Transportation shall
include in its
banal budget requests under RSA 9 col 4
funding for any administrative cost
related to the maintenance of traffic
signal preemption technology systems
used for emergency vehicles could you
explain briefly uh what administrative
costs mean I'm a little bit I'm whole on
this whole subject I'm a nvie
so I am not sure exactly what that
refers to as well um there is a uh there
is a cost to operating our
maintenance um unit at uh at the Bureau
of traffic um there's a cost for uh the
staff the people the uh oversight the
training uh and so forth uh I think
expanding um the number of Crews as
necessary uh will increase um the
overall cost of operation the overhead
so to speak um also there will be
increased interactions with each of the
municipalities uh as we uh go through
and
um upgrade the systems bring them up
into operation uh to full operation and
um kind of like I said level the playing
field uh I'm I can't really get into
what those costs might be at this point
I'm not sure exactly what that refers to
follow chairman followup please okay
okay yeah a question I know this this
bill hasn't become law yet if it be
passes it would become law I guess
written July 1st of 2025 do you know of
any plans that the department has or any
requ preliminary requests because I
realize the governor hasn't submitted
her budget yet about including money in
its in its budget request for
administrative costs for this not not in
response to this this bill um it is um
if if it be
becomes um we we are we are not
financially prepared for the additional
burden of of Performing this additional
level of work uh without additional
funding okay thank
you thank you representative Jack uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
coming uh you've been very clear that
municipalities understand that after the
signal is installed they're responsible
for maintenance and yet the prime
sponsor uh is is issuing a cry for help
that the ones on the state roads the
maintenance is declining and the
municipalities work great do we have any
either data or can you uh speculate on
on how it can be that that that
condition that that the maintenance that
the town knows they're supposed to do
isn't
happening I guess it would be
speculation I don't know the particular
uh municipality involved and I don't I
don't necessarily have the details I
don't interact on this topic uh um our
signal maintenance Crews interact with
the towns um
so it's it's easily I would think it
could be easily misunderstood that you
know a a state-owned signal uh you
wouldn't necessarily expect that a
municipality would have responsibility
for parts of it um it in our business
it's not unusual but it you know it it I
I I I'm not surprised if if there's a
misunderstanding um but that is a it has
been a long-standing policy established
when we first started dealing with
opticom and preemption um and it may be
the municipalities are not aware and so
as as issues come up we we try to make
them aware share
that
followup uh if that's the case can we do
some Outreach to the towns and the fire
departments to make sure they know who
they're supposed to be reporting
problems to and who's responsible for
fixing them yes we can do that yep thank
you representative
Boger thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question when y'all install U when
there's road work done and you're going
to install a new signal system in the
town asked y'all to add this Opticon
type
thing y'all do a memorandum of
understanding on the scope of the work
that being done and the
responsibilities thereof and is it
spelled out in the I call it memorandum
of understanding which takes care of who
does what and who's responsible for what
and what not would that not have been
spelled out in that document yeah there
was um we have um a history of varying
levels of documentation in the past um
we now all projects have Municipal
agreements U that are part of the
project so if work is being done within
a
municipality um all these items are
detailed um
historically uh I can't say that that
has been done um back in the original um
days that you know handshakes and
understandings um you know life was a
bit simpler then and uh uh you know
going back and EST lishing those those
agreements is not hasn't been
necessarily a um a mission that we've
we've had so we've you know we deal with
it going
forward followup
please and as you follow up and do
upgrades and stuff that would fall under
that memorandum uh at that point when
y'all do your upgrades and stuff to
something that's existing and that way
you can catch up from past to the
present ye yes we do when when there's
um projects that are done and traffic
signals have very long lives uh so it's
not often that one is removed and
completely replaced um we we have them
added um but generally the existing
intersections don't see too much work um
so as new new projects come in and take
um establish new traffic signals that's
part of the the maintenance agreements
do we have any other further questions
representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
today might I understand that the in a
situation where a a town takes care of a
traffic opticom
system uh that signal case be um it it's
being uh accessed by those by the town
but that signal case is owned by the
state of New Hampshire
correct the the signal cabinet uh the
silver or black cabinet on the side of
the road in the corner um is is property
of the State uh the within that cabinet
would be components that are provided by
the
town um so if an OP if a preemption
system were added to a traffic signal
after the initial construction uh that
would be in there uh and like I said
when we do new signals we include it as
part of the project um but that becomes
part of uh the municipality's
responsibility okay and just a quick
followup thank you Mr chairman uh does
the municipality alert you or is there
an alarm or something that feeds back to
a control point that says somebody's in
that case other than your technicians in
in the signal crew of the State of New
Hampshire generally they contact us for
access to the cabinets um the
there to answer your question no there's
not some sort of indication that someone
else is in the cabinets um that's a
that's another issue um different topic
for a different day um but it is uh you
know within the within the understanding
of uh uh we we we work with the towns uh
and we're familiar with those that have
traffic signal Crews uh city of conquer
for instance they'll call our chief
technician and say I need to work at you
know Fort Eddie Road and we we're
familiar with their capabilities and and
trust them and um they access that and
can do their work without us being there
in other cases if there's someone we're
not familiar with or um or it's a
contractor we may have a technician come
out and meet them and then they learn
together um sometimes we can help them
and they can help us understand what
they're
doing thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you very much Mr
bronis and at this point in time I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
it being
11 13 and we're running a little behind
uh I now open the public hearing on
hb300 uh the prime sponsor isn't here
I'm going to recognize John cluder to
introduce the bill please okay thank you
Mr chairman I want to be clear that I'm
just here today to introduce the bill on
behalf of the Prime sponsor repesent
Oregon who cannot be here and I don't
know the reason so I take no position on
this bill and I would respectfully
decline any questions because I don't
really have a a set position on this
bill so I wouldn't be very helpful and I
think you should listen to the rest of
testimony for people who both favor and
oppose this bill or or can add give us
some technical expertise thank you thank
you this point I'd like to call on Mr
Jason Briggs please to oppose this
bill Mr
Briggs welcome to public works please
introduce
yourself the please press the button on
the mic than you my name is Jason Briggs
and I work for the Conway Scenic
Railroad in North Conway New Hampshire
and um I want to thank you Mr chairman
and The Honorable Guest The Honorable
members of uh this committee for
allowing me to
testify and I'd like to thank you first
of all I've testified in Maine over 30
years for different venues and no
committee has ever sat and listened
every single one of you to what people
have had to say people are up and moving
and leaving and you do a great job and I
respect that and uh it means a lot to
those of us that testify that you listen
and um you're the winner in that
department thank you
um we oppose this particular bill um
Conway Scenic Railroad has 57 miles of
track that they negotiate with the New
Hampshire Department of
Transportation we get no subsidy and and
no funds uh to operate that with the
state of New Hampshire we uh operate it
at our own expense and take care of the
work that needs to be done the train
this year or in 2024 carried 150,000
passengers it's doubled since 19 uh I
mean 2018 when uh the SS um took
over we employ 76 to 80 people full-time
and we never lay anyone off in the
winter or during a slow season everybody
continues to get their pay salary or a
minimum of their 40
hours we oppose it because this
particular bill in section or line four
through 8 for example um to assess the
costs and incomes related to the removal
of rail and ties were necessary to
provide a level safe surface for
recreational activities on the existing
track
bed well I'll give you an example once
the tracks are gone that's very diff ult
to put them back and you in this state
are very fortunate to have some
wonderful train operators you have
private sector that offer tours which is
a huge economic impact to your state and
now with the new operation of CSX taking
over from PanAm is a better partner for
most people and other rail programs that
take uh that operate here in your great
state that Conway Branch uh believe it
or not goes all the way to
Portland um and it's called the mountain
division so Conway Scenic has to the
fryberg line fryberg Maine for example
has a great uh Trail and train
track uh setup the trail runs next to
the tracks so that if they were ever
needed which they're not being operated
on right
now and uh um it's a great working
relationship fryberg did an amazing job
other communities in Maine once the
smaller communities have found out that
the responsibility of the trails is
their town to upkeep have become
concerned because they have to plow it
they have to mow the grass they have to
pick up the trash put out the
receptacles all that sort of thing cuz
in Maine for example the do or Trails
folks do not take responsibility of
cleaning up or tending to the trail so I
don't know what that circumstance would
be here in the great state of New
Hampshire but that's been a bon of
contention for some of the smaller folks
a smaller communities just because some
of them only have one or two employees
that are in their Highway
division
so the Environmental Protection
Agency says that we produce trains that
offer Freight and passenger rail service
1.7% of greenhouse gas admissions
compared to 58.5 produced by cars 23.4
produced by trucks in the United
States passenger rail is even Greener
coming in at 0. 2% in general moving
Freight by rail instead of trucks
reduces our admissions by
75% the time is now to maintain and
develop rail infr in
infrastructure so that we can build
towards a stronger and Greener
future railroads are secured considered
secure infrastructure which
significantly benefits any Property
Owners adjacent to the track and I
mentioned uh the abutters um Express
great con concern about creating free
access to the trail systems because
again I use Maine it becomes a homeless
Highway and that's where tent cities and
that s things start to start to
develop so New Hampshire has a lot
of great operators that are in the
railroad business whether it be Scenic
or
commercial um committees to review and
to do studies always cost a lot of money
and you seem to have a system right now
if it ain't broke don't fix it so um we
hope that um you will vote down this
particular SP
sp300 and I appreciate your time thank
you Mr Briggs is there any questions for
Mr Briggs from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony sir thank
you at this point in time I'd like to
call on do miss Shelly Winters
please welcome to Public Works long time
no
see I think I'll be here a lot so thank
you so for the matter of the record my
name is Shelley Winters I'm the director
of the division of Aeronautics Rail and
trans at the Department of
Transportation um here just to provide
some um maybe some testimony some some
background of perhaps for your
consideration about the duplicative
nature of this in comparison to House
Bill 1468 that was was passed last year
and directing the department to work
through a process uh to develop a a
Planning Group to look at the Conway
Branch so the state owns 21 miles of the
Conway Branch it does connect uh new
North Coast and active freight line to
con weic um who are a great partner to
us last year under house bill 1468 and
we delivered the report to the governor
and executive Council and and members of
this committee earlier this year in
January we convened a Planning Group to
look at the the best use and best value
to the state currently for the 21 miles
of State own Corridor and um can submit
a copy of of the report for the record
and and for you to share but essentially
the outcome of that was that based on
the public input and participation from
members of the public communities
through which this Corridor goes and
elected officials is that um it should
be used for an interim use as a
recreational rail trail so the
Department of Transportation and the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources of which um one of my cohorts
is here we are in the process of
effectuating a transfer of the
management of the 21 miles from do to
dncr and then dncr would be working
through their normal process of um rail
to Trail conversion and and what that
would look like we don't know how that
will play out over time but uh we
believe that uh you know the the product
has been delivered and the wheels are in
motion to go to governor and Council by
by March so by and large we've gone
through a public process with public
meetings um stakeholders convened and um
the department will retain uh a
reversionary clause so if in the future
funds should be availed for rail or
other more mass transportation uses the
state will still own this property it
will just be the day-to-day management
will be deferred to dncr and the interim
use will be recreational uh recreational
is not a game or a mode or what the
Department of Transportation normally
does so again we wanted to give it to
our sister agency who could better work
with the the users and the funding
sources that support that so um with
that I'm happy to take any questions
thank you Mr MERS uh representative Jack
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for appearing uh starting on line 12
this bill also establishes a general
study committee to study rail uh if I'm
not mistaken we have a state rail plan
and wouldn't that also be uh somewhat
duplicative that's another good point
yes sir uh so right now the department
is um updating its state rail plan it
was last done in about
2012 we're in the midst of uh public
hearings and meetings for that in a
stakeholder group and that report for
the updated State rail plan is planned
to be delivered within this calendar
year so um looking at the the rail
network from a holistic um would
probably be covered by by that ongoing
effort representative
Bogart thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
um I don't remember what bill it was
last year but this committee heard a
bill that was going to remove track
back in somewhere in that area and turn
it over the trail is this the 21 miles
that are being discussed now yes there
were a few different bills last year
some of them were more prescriptively
looking at smaller subsets 10 miles or
so but uh yeah so the effort we looked
at was aimed at that 10 miles originally
of track removal but we looked at the
whole 21 miles cuz to the department
it's a contiguous Corridor so the
effects of a 10 mile decision affect 20
mil so um it is the same
representative
follow so it was then uh passed and
agreed upon to go ahead and and do this
and the
do has been actively working towards
converting it uh removing Rail and
converting it to a
trail and this bill I'm sorry it's a
longer question but and this bill would
kind of stop that process and and reset
it to leaving the tracks in place and
doing something different is that the
scope I'm understanding so line in one
line one and line two direct the
department to request you know to submit
an RFP to look for on rail uses and and
by and large the department has agreed
to foro that as part of the direct under
house bill 1468 from last session um and
then looked at the interim recreational
uses so we have not actively removed any
rail when we do the the management
transfer to Department of Natural and
cultural resources they will work
through um any stages or phases of rail
removal as they develop trails and
that's not a foregone conclusion because
there is some interest and some
recreational on rail uses whether it's
motorized putt puts rail biking so again
dncr now let them speak to it I believe
we'll have um an interactive process
with the host communities to figure out
what will be going on but there's no
planned active rail use Freight or
passenger rail that would occur upon the
transfer from do to
dncr any other questions yes
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman I just want to make sure I'm
I'm clear on this so um Mr Briggs
indicated they have 80 jobs uh that are
supported by the existing in Conway
railro and 150,000 passengers per year
use it now the the section that we're
talking about the 21 miles that includes
the existing Conway Scenic Railroad
use no 21 miles of the state owned
Conway Branch are the state owned
privately for which we have no tenant
railroads so the department has an
agreement with Conway Scenic on its
Mountain division the line that um goes
uh east west across the state to the to
the main line so we have no tenant
railroads who we will be um who are
actively providing service that we will
be severing any agreements with okay so
these are follow follow so these are
basically 21 miles that's independent of
the existing use correct correct it
connects south of their private
ownership Conway Scenic owns some
private portions of the Conway Branch
the northern po piece of the Conway
branch is owned by Conway Scenic so the
21 miles to the south of that are
abandoned and have only been used for
winter snowmobile use by dncr so
okay thank
you any other
questions representative jurus thank you
Mr chairman thank you for being here so
there's when it goes to
dnca there's will there be any work I
guess they're going to come up to
testify but will there be any pursuit of
a possible uh Rail caror
between um our section of that that
railroad all the way out to to Portland
Maine so that would be on the mountain
division so that would be separate from
these 21 miles so our 21 miles go north
connect to Conway Scenic and then
connect to the state own Mountain
division which runs from the main Town
Line over to well the main border over
to the Vermont border so um dncr
wouldn't have any interface or
interaction on any grants or development
on the mountain division to fryberg
thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you Miss
Winters do we have any other
speakers seeing
none can move to close the public
hearing on
hb300 thank
you we' got it's been an hour and a half
we've got a couple of minutes before we
have to start uh HP 100 if anybody wants
to take about 3 minutes to uh restroom
it or not you may
go we'll we will open up the public here
in about three minutes thank
you
e
e e
it's being 11:34 I'm going to call the
public hearing on House Bill
100 prohibiting the use of State funds
for new passenger rail projects to order
and I recognize representative Ross
Berry thank you and thank you Mr
chairman for um hearing me out I'm here
to introduce uh House Bill 100 which
would prohibit new passenger Rail
Products I do think the bill probably
does need an amendment because I think
the language is a little clunky um the
purpose of it is specifically designed
to stop the um the project number
40818 which is the Nashua Manchester
Cocker quote unquote commuter rail um so
this has been that particular project
I'm going to leave my remarks to that
particular project which is why I signed
on to the bill uh it is time that we as
a state accept that this is never going
to happen we keep spending more and more
and more taxpayer money trying to study
something that is never going to happen
this particular stretch has been in
place before two times and both times it
has gone under because people didn't
want to write it so it it's like uh you
know I there was this movie by Lizzy
Lohan a couple years ago called mean
girl and one of the characters kept
using this word fetch she's like and she
would try to interject it you know oh
that's so fetch that's so fetch and
finally they told her stop trying to
make fetch happen fetch is never going
to
happen this Commuter Rail Project 40818
the one between Nash and conquered is
fetch it is never going to happen we now
live in a different world from when
commuter rail would have actually been
somewhat feasible so we now live in a
world where more and more people are
working from home more and more people
want to work from home um and the need
for this is basically gone there the
proponents of the project are always
putting forward kind of these fantasy
lands things that it wouldn't do like oh
you'll be able to jump on the train at
at you know six o'clock in Manchester
and go catch a game at finway no you're
that that's not how it works it's
Commuter so it's people leaving in the
morning to go to work people coming back
from
work when we look forward in the future
rail is probably not going to be the way
that humans transport themselves the
Advent of electronic of electric
vehicles and the Advent of autonomous
vehicles are basically going to replace
anyone wanting to get on a fixed mode of
transportation um it also erases the
enironmental concerns that rail might be
better for than a CO2 emitting car if
you have a fully electronic vehicle that
you can charge with clean energy and it
will take you exactly where you want to
go and you never have to touch the
steering wheel why would you get on a
rail why would you ever do that you
wouldn't so when they proposed this
project before they always have it's
like like the same formula which is
every time they study it they project
less ridership and it costing more so
less ridership costing more every single
time they go through this iteration of
fewer Riders more money and I think
you're actually at a point now where
projected ridership would be lower than
the number of people that that train
going through there eight times a day
would disturb so I used to live right by
the proposed rail uh right now that
train track it sees a
train maybe once every two days um let's
just call it once every day just for the
sake of benefit um it's very disturbing
when that train comes through there the
Train's been running there I think since
like 1910 or something it's not new but
it's you know the house is Shake right
it's but it's it's one of those things
of like you know you bought the house
the tracks were there but you kind of
knew the frequency of the schedule this
is talking about bringing a train
through there eight 16 times a day So a
multiple a multiple a a multiplier of
how much time that train is going to be
going through there that no one will be
writing just being honest with yourself
no one's going to write it so you're
going to disturb a bunch of people bunch
of single family homes uh starter homes
by the way uh they're going to serve a
bunch of people they're not going to
ride it then you're going to take going
to raise their taxes because the fee the
the fees you would charge won't cover
the cost so you're going to tax them
more you're going to decrease the value
of the house you're going to disturb
them all so that you can have some
project that no one's going to ride uh
and I I'll leave you with this one if
commu rail was going to be a thing if if
that if that track was going to run
again that the third iteration of it
because it's already failed twice if
that was going to run again someone
would already do it the people that own
those tracks Want A train running on
those tracks They want to monetize those
tracks if they thought that they could
be economically feasible to have that
train running and make money I assure
you as greedy capitalist they would do
it but it doesn't work unless the
taxpayers fund out a bunch of money so
they're not going to do that it's time
we just put this issue to bed and accept
that this is never going to be a thing
um they had a vote I think last week in
nasua and maybe two weeks ago um where
they actually discussed spending
Municipal money on this project and I
think they stopped it by one vote
because somebody finally kind of said
what I was said Nash was the people that
the Alman of Nash are not exactly of uh
my political persuasion someone finally
said why are we spending a quarter of a
million dollars on project that's never
going to happen when we have homeless
people freezing in the streets that fin
somebody finally said the quiet part out
loud um and they also recognize the
reality which was they said I won't see
the rail my children won't see the rail
but maybe my children's children will
see the rail so let's stop spending
money on things that are never going to
happen let's just acknowledge it's not a
thing and we just we just move on so uh
I have to be very brief in questions cuz
I'm in committee right now too um so
I'll take like one or two but I'm I'm
basically going to going to Ro so I'm
sorry to do that but if I wasn't in
committee I'd stay here and have a have
a good time thank you Mr Ro
representative Ross representative Jack
has it uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for appearing I'm curious why you
want to stop project
40818 which was completed two years ago
in February of of 2023 and is no longer
in the 10-year plan or any funds being
expended on it well it's the NASA I said
I don't know the project number because
that's was in the bill I'm not the prime
sponsor as I said but the the I'm I'm
discussing the Nash Manchester conquered
corridor so so long as that rail is not
running that's the intention of the bill
um you know I I said I'm not I'm here as
a I'm here as a courtesy to the prime
sponsor so okay follow up then uh there
is no currently funded project in this
Corridor so it seems like your goal is
achieved without this bill I I would
disagree because someone will bring it
back it just keeps coming back they've
already brought it back to they've
already brought it back twice so if it's
dead for a third time it'll be back and
forth put it to bed and I I do got to go
with that one
because you're excused I'm sure there'll
be other people answer any
questions representative
B
please welcome to public
works thank you Mr chairman state your
name and for the record please all right
I'm Ralph B and correcting what I
printed out I'm in Hillsboro District
38 town of Hudson and and
Lichfield thank you anyway commuta rail
in the early 90s I was on Jud Greg's
Railway commission we studied bringing
commuter rail to nashwa we had many
meetings for a year and including
representatives from the
MBTA after a year discussing and looking
at the issues determined that computer
rail was not financially
feasible more so now it was determined
that the tracks from low up would have
to be completely replaced and include
turnoff tracks the existing track is 15
mph Freight and worse now is there are
less train traffic 15 mph Freight that
you can
contribute make believe it's a class six
Road a dirt road you can't put highspeed
rail on
it of course the initial course of the
trains the upkeep Etc or that coming
from my other pocket the one that pays
federal income taxes the MBT operation
in Massachusetts is paid for by their
sales tax and property tax for most of
the towns east of
495 50 years ago I lived in Hudson Mass
and it was on our property tax pill for
subsidizing the MBTA and the train
didn't even go through Hudson
towns are assessed even though no Grail
goes through the
town the people that ride the train do
not pay for the cost of it it is all
subsidized the whole world is subsidized
for rail
Transportation except for what I
understand the Tokyo rail system and
they use people to push the PE push the
passengers onto the
train and we know that and we've heard
about a lot of well the down Easter the
train that goes from Maine to Boston
that's Amtrak that's subsidizes by
your income
tax and they're in
trouble the argument that all
transportation and subsidized only go so
far yes in our property taxes we pay for
Road plowing improvements Etc but that
we can control by our vote but Road
Transportation benefits 100% of us all
we have to eat the trucks bring the food
we get mail and all that so that's
entirely different we all use the
roads instead of spending money on
trains the Manny should be spent on New
Hampshire making it more cost effective
for businesses to move to New Hampshire
so that the workers don't have to
compute and we heard that a lot of them
are
remotely and if Manchester and Nashville
W trains they can pay for it there was a
trade run once back in the 90s and I
think it lasted a year because it wasn't
being utilized So and I've always been
let those that use a service pay for it
my gas taxes go for the road and one of
the problems we have is e EV vehicles
are using the road for free and that
needs to be fixed so thank
you any questions for representative
bone representative
fauler quick one are you aware that EVS
in fact are charged
$100 regist but that's still a whole lot
less than what I'm paying for gas gas
taxes equivalent of 500 gallons yeah
which would take me in my car 50,000
miles I I realize that that that was
just started
recently any other questions
representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you uh
representative B uh when you lived in
Hudson Mass did and part of the the town
may have uh been part of the communities
in mass that uh were uh were charged
with supporting the te the town of
Hudson had uh he still had commuter rail
stops in in either Acton or Fitchburg
that uh that those residents could could
access yeah but back then we looked at
who was riding the riding the trails and
we did a survey and whatnot and we
figured hey we can ride these people to
van and be cheaper you know I mean than
the property taxes and I know people in
all the towns in mayard and Hudson in
that whole area really were very upset
that that was on their property tax bill
then and it'd be worse now in New
Hampshire can you imagine if I'm living
in litfield and I had this thing on my
property tax bill for subsidizing that
madebe nobody used
so follow up is it is it would you
understand that it's possible that right
now residents of litfield and Hudson
commute to either L the Gallagher
Terminal of North Bara station to catch
the commuter rail or possibly even drive
down the air wife to catch the uh the
red
line I don't know of anybody that would
that would use conceivably if the if I
could follow conceivably if the trade
sto were in Nashville those residents
could conceivably you know cross the
bridge and and go to the station in Nash
correct well one yeah one of the things
we have in that we have
the the the Boston the Boston Express
that goes through 91 and three the bus
line the problem in nashar is the bus
line mainly for nashar people is in
tingbo there's one in Northern hash
but I mean it the problem when we had
the the commission was finding a place
in nashille for putting the train
station to start with nobody wanted it
but now and then people looking at it
and that was even Fez and Lane mall we
thought that would be a great place for
it but Fez and Lan Mall's said no way
you know because people can come up and
Shop but you know so it wasn't feasible
then financially for the course of the
trains the subsidies that would be
needed and you know and it' be it' be
worse now and like previous speaker
mentioned it
was less and less people going to
Massachusetts now and we want the people
to come up to New Hampshire to work
people stay in New Hampshire to work and
not have to commute to
Massachusetts any further questions for
representative B representative
cludia question represent
conern apologize okay I am concerned
that the way this bill is presently
written would this it sounds like it
could apply to the Cog Railway we with
no more State funding for the Cog
because it is a passenger railroad even
though it's mainly used just I think for
tourism so I think are you concerned
about that because I just noticed this
in reading the
language um yeah I think yeah but I
think they came up before and I thought
this language had fixed that but I'm not
sure okay all right thank
you any further questions for
representative B representative
Edgar uh thank you Mr chair um
this would prevent I guess the
completion I I guess I'll probably get
some help with this but the uh the
completion of the report that was being
done all the money was spent on so that
we could actually see comprehensively
what what the costs were at least ex
going to be prophesized to be Bic
calculated that we then we' be able to
make a a better decision a lot of people
if they saw the actual report if there
was an official one put out then people
make a decision be a lot of people would
say no this this doesn't make sense or
they might say yes it does make sense
based on a report this would prevent
that from coming out yeah the current
one I don't know what the status is of
the the one that had mentioned I know
there was a report done when I was on
Jud Greg's commission but uh the latest
one what I understand I don't know I
haven't seen it and I don't know if
one's been out followup uh thank you Mr
chair but if if this goes through then
we wouldn't be able to have the a final
final report that everybody could take a
look at and judge or make a decision um
wouldn't that be better than would that
be better than just throwing out
different things that might be wrong
with it but the thing is it's like I
mean testimony mine and the previous is
like less and less people are going to
be using the rail and why do we need it
and why we want to continue spending
money on something that will probably
never
happen thank you thank you any further
questions for representative bom rep
representative
rockmore I'll get
it thank you Mr chairman um do you
understand this bill to prohibit the
state from say repairing a a a track
that carries Freight because that also
would be because that track might also
carry passengers and the state has its
hands tied it can't money on a TR when I
understand the track now that does the
freight is owned by the company that
runs the
trains the problem is if we if we do the
pass rain all that track north of LEL up
would have to be completely replaced
along with turnoff tracks in other words
for a train that turn off has another
trains coming so that track so that
track would probably have to be used
State money to do it because the com
current company
I mean if they were going to do rail
they would be doing it I mean commuter
rail they would be doing it and nobody
wants to do
it follow up thank you um the situation
I'm imagining is say the co Scenic the
conoy Scenic Railway says we have some
broken track we're a wonderful employer
in the state we're a great tourist
attraction could the state pitch in a
little bit to help us repair this track
and with this law we would would have to
say no we absolutely cannot do
that am I understanding this correctly
we have a budget problem now how much
money are we going to spend and where
are we going to get the money to spend
it thank
you representative
Newman yes thank you um I had just read
an article uh a few days ago about the
Cog Railway is looking to go electri now
that gets State support so how would
passage of this legislation affect work
that's going on with that isn't the Cog
Railway owned by is that estate owned
I'm not aware of it's not here copy the
article oh I'm s I'm not aware that I
thought that was a private
owned it does get State support whatever
the definition of of that could
Encompass so
I guess I would put that question to you
what would you see to that could that
stop everything but I think the Cog
Railway I mean that's pretty much
self-supporting and I think if you
know it it does have state support I
guess I I'll leave it at that I don't
know to what to what the amount is I'm
not aware of that like
okay yeah and repres I'm going to step
in a little bit here I want to keep this
conversation limited to this current
bill right now and I I I think I might
be able to help on some of this this
bill does say it prohibits prohibits the
use of State funds for new passenger
rail service okay not cogra not existing
not anything else okay representative
Jack uh Mr chairman uh the uh title of
the bill does say new however if you
actually read the
bill it says for the planning
construction operation or management of
and does not say
new don't sounds like
it maybe an amendment is needed maybe it
does sound like
that anyway if there are no further
questions for representative
bom we can move on to the other speakers
thank
you I'm going to call
Representative St Clair please welcome
to Public Works state your name for the
record thank you Mr chair it is DED a
pleasure to be here my name is Charlie
stclair excuse me from uh District 5
lonia uh a couple things on some of this
I first of all getting back to the last
time the commuter train ran from Boston
to conquer excuse
me that uh ended in 1980 I believe it
was in January February of 1980 there's
been nothing since then up through that
Corridor and we're talking about the
railroad company that owns that track
now South that CSX now uh the people
that owned them before Guilford uh spent
no money on the tracks and it was indeed
10 to 15 miles an hour CSX is now in the
progress of upgrading all their track uh
throughout New England with since
they've bought all this track uh and you
can see their equipment out there
working all the
time the down Easter was mentioned uh
obviously I'm not in support of this
bill the down Easter has been mentioned
a couple
times if you're on that train which I am
a lot because I I just can't stand 93 so
I go drive the DOA to catch it to Boston
uh on days when there are Red Sox games
um Celtics Bruins the train is full of
their fans so for somebody to say that
that doesn't happen that that's just not
the case and I would encourage you to
take the train on those days to see it
there are five train sets a day running
between Brunswick Maine and
Boston many many many New Hampshire
people get on in exiter Dover and even
Durham uh I watch them this past month
the train uh reached its 10 millionth
passenger that was my briefcase my 10th
million it's 10th million passenger the
train has been doing
fine um so what I did when this bill
came up
before was I put a petition at my
business up in lonia and I just set it
there I didn't talk to many people about
it when I did they would usually uh just
say what with regards to this bill so I
want to hand these in it just says we
the undersign request the state of New
Hampshire invest in the development of
Passenger rail service through
throughout the state where possible I am
a resident of New Hampshire there's
approximately 600 here if I had made
this my goal in life I could have had
thousands and there's no doubt about
that I was encouraged to do an online
petition but I thought this would look a
little more uh just look a little more
power to it so I I'll leave that here
and uh please uh if you're not going to
use them I'd love to have it back I want
to remind everybody that we all know
public transportation
never pays for itself the airlines are
subsidized we subsidize the bus to
Boston some of the buses say right on
them owned and operated by New Hampshire
do I have no problem with that that's
called a wide openen public
transportation system one shoe does not
fit all we support the Airlines lonia
airport gets an incredible amount of
government subsidy there's not even any
commercial flights out of there this is
this is just not a Common Sense bill and
I I really really encourage you to kill
this bill take any questions any
questions please for representative St
Clair representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman uh representative thank you for
being here today uh is it possible that
some of those fans for who catch the
down Easter from Dober or Durham uh
those the instead of those fans in
Nashua or the surrounding areas going
down to Bara or uh or or L would they
could it be possible to take the train
from the uh specific location as
designated on Crown Street which is wide
open right now in Nash are ready for a
station could they could they catch the
train there going Southbound to low then
into into North Station that conceivable
absolutely and I went to a meeting when
there was talk several years ago about
bringing the train up to Manchester or
conquered um and there were
Representatives here from the fisher
cats uh who are just dreaming of this
service coming up because they said what
a a boom it would be to to their games
there uh and again I talking to lonia my
constituents in lonia um same thing they
they just really don't understand why
this hasn't already been done I remind
everybody that the initial startup would
be with Federal money our tax dollars
coming back to help us in New Hampshire
what a what a switch that with would be
because when we don't take that money
that's out there for this type of
Transportation it just goes to other
states they're there with their hands
wide open saying yeah we'll take it
we'll take it this would be a a
wonderful boom not just for commuter but
for tourism you again you take the down
Easter you'll see people on there with
suitcases look at the development that's
going on in DOA around the station it's
incredible the buildings that have gone
up all housing and because people will
take the train they want to live near
the station and dover's done a great job
of uh reaching out to that so there's so
much of it out there I made the offer
the last time I spoke here if somebody
doesn't know about the down Easter I'll
be more than happy to purchase you a
ticket and take you on a tour I believe
I've done that with one of your uh
members here uh just to show how many
people get on in New Hampshire and how
many people move to New Hampshire
because they didn't want to live in
Massachusetts so they moved here yes
they work in Massachusetts but they now
live in New Hampshire the residents here
they pay taxes it it's it helps the
bottom line right across the
board I think you just a quick followup
follow if you would uh so okay we
mentioned going Southbound but is it
sounds like it's almost possible for
commuters that come Northbound to go to
events you mentioned the the ball game
in in in Manchester but also to to work
is it possible for those commuters who
live
us down the line to come Northbound to
work in places like Nashville or
Manchester um knowing too that uh the C
the Alantic Chambers the Alantic uh
Committee in in nashille voted to um to
put the uh put the rail uh study into
the into the budget for next year as
opposed to passing it in this past
session this in a bill with other B with
other uh bills uh so would that is that
possible as well oh question is and I
and I agree with the people that say
we've studied this stuff to death and
they're spending a lot of money studying
something year after year when new
members come into the government uh I
would just say take a look over to the
coastal communities and how they've
profited from this and how um how the
state of Maine is now lengthened the the
um the route that the Train's gone over
there I mean this is not not rocket
science I don't think I it's going to
cost money everything we do cost money
with regards to
Transportation
everything one more real quick followup
sorry Mr chairman thank you very much as
long as it pertains to this bill
representative jurors not about traffic
either way how and what's possible right
now as long as it pertains to this bill
you're recognized for a followup if
thank you so Federal money it was talked
about Federal money to to start this
effort up is it possible that the
federal money would help uh in the spur
lines uh who talked about the CSX tracks
to to upgrade those tracks and to also
uh install the SP lines in places like
Manchester and ashaa absolutely okay
absolutely and I remind everybody that
when the down Easter that's all we have
to go on besides the the voner over
there on the west side of the state when
the down Easter F came first uh was
proposed and was being built you may
look back to the screaming headlines in
the union leader what a boondoggle that
was going to be in a waste of tax tax
money because nobody was going to ride
it and I would not agree with that
office thank you any further
questions representative
vone thank you Mr chairman uh Mr L clerk
were you aware that the New Hampshire
executive Council approved $1.2 million
in a loan to the Cog uh Railway line
Improvement to the Cog railroad yeah no
I was not aware of that and and uh since
I don't use the Cog railro which is a
very great tourist destination uh I it
somehow would slipped by me I'm not
aware of that at all so would you I'm
I'm sorry follow up thank you so would
you categorize that as a
subsidy Well yeah if they're giving
money to anything it's a subsidy thank
you absolutely thank
you further questions representative
Boyd thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative St Clair for taking my CH
uh question in your previous testimony
you talked anecdotally about the Fisher
Cats management team enjoying the idea
of traffic coming up from Boston to
Manchester the question is is there any
data from the down Easter that would
support Northbound traffic going to
Portland Main to see the Sea Dogs at
adlock field I am absolutely positive
there would be that data uh and I think
that it would be very easy to uh to
reach out and get that uh the down
Easter's headquarters is in Portland
Maine I do not have the woman's name in
front of me that's in charge of that but
they keep very good records of of uh all
their passengers the tickets they sell
where they get on where they get off
they're very good at that so I would
that can be found easily and if somebody
doesn't want to do it and I was tasked
with doing that I'd be more than happy
to help the committee with that follow
up Mr CH followup please followup
question regarding anecdotally
about the the possibility of rail coming
north
through through nashille in into
Manchester is there any data on the as
it relates to the Down East regarding
the number of people traveling north
that are actually getting off at
Ogunquit Old Orchard Beach
pre-established locations with amenities
already in place that are traveling
north because it's easy to go north get
off absolutely there would be thank you
and I think that's a great question and
I think it's well worth somebody
following up
uh good question any further questions
saying none thank you representative St
Clair and I can't thank you enough for
giving me this privilege thank you quite
welcome call on representative Jess
Edwards
please uh thank you Mr chair I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Auburn candy and Deerfield um that's
Rockingham District 31 I'm a co-sponsor
of this bill uh I think I wrote on the
card I'm going to take a minute maybe
two so I'm I'm going to be blunt um I
budgets are about
priorities uh as I look at the budget uh
we have uh a lot of priorities uh we
have potentially needing to step in and
and do a better job funding our pensions
uh we need to take a look at upgrading
um uh the state contributions to
education we're still liable for a
massive lawsuit related to
YDC um so for the next few years I think
we have some very strategic things that
we need to U uh keep our eye on and as a
risk mitigation approach I do not think
we should be taking on uh new spending
uh
possibilities uh I don't think a
passenger train is paid for itself
anywhere in the United States I believe
the previous testimony uh uh of the
representative in favor of this bill
stated that uh I have um a lot of
experience having lived in California
with the uh the bullet train to Nowhere
um uh they they've spent billions on
that it caused them to take their eye
off the ball they didn't invest in fire
prevention and and uh fire reduction and
so that that's a real world example of
how trying to spend too much money and
not keeping your priorities straight
lead to other disasters and so so I I
would just encourage us to continue
moratorium on spending General funds on
H this particular project because uh
there there are vastly more ways to
spend our money that would probably do
better for all of our citizens that
that's my testimony thank you
representative will you take questions
sure questions for representative
Edwards representative Boyd thank you Mr
chairman representative Edwards thank
you for taking my question would you
believe that the proposed nashille
Manchester conquered line goes through
an8 Mile Stretch of rail in the town of
marac which would impact four
neighborhoods and require the town to
spend 60 million taxpayer dollars to
move of the town's own sewer intercept a
line with no train station being
proposed for the town uh that's not at
all surprising that's what happens when
Central planning steps in and and
doesn't take a look at the real local
needs that's why this is better done by
the private sector I'd also point out
that that line of rail would not benefit
the the citizens of of Chester Auburn
candy or deer
Deerfield thank you Mr chairman any
further questions
representative Edwards you got off easy
thank you for your
testimony good
launch Peggy Gilmore please welcome to
public
works and you are from the nationville
Chamber of
Commerce that's correct and thank you Mr
chair for the record Peggy Gilmore
representing the greater nashille
Chamber of Commerce I hadn't planned to
speak but but did want to bring uh the
business perspective to this the Nash
chamber has long supported the potential
I say the potential for having passenger
rail that would come to nashille and
onto Manchester and perhaps onto conquer
but that really
wasn't so much um in the feasibility of
the feasibility
and the reason that the chamber has
supported this is because the proven
Economic Development that's shown when
there is uh good Transportation good
rail service through an area also uh the
stay workor play or people who have
looked at what uh incentivizes young
people to live in the southern part of
the state
particularly is access to Boston and so
it's seen as the the potential for rail
passenger rail Boston to man to
Nashville and Manchester is seen as an
incentivize to bring young people here
and the rail goes two ways and we have
seen a bad Workforce shortage in the in
New Hampshire and there is able
Workforce we have on our
board uh someone who runs a staffing
agency and she has said if she could get
ra pass an easy passenger transport to
Nashua she could fill several jobs so
that's anecdotal the other thing I'd
say as a prior legislature it to
me it's not good policy to prohibit
something now not knowing what the
future will bring as representative Jack
said this particular project is not
currently in the 10-year plan but who
knows what we're going to
want and how we're going to set our
priorities as the future comes um things
change Transportation has changed we see
it we don't know what changes are going
to come and we don't know what the
future will bring around this and so it
seems that it's not a good idea to
prohibit something not knowing what will
be the future and this committee this
this I think is the third time this bill
has come before this committee first
time it was somewhere it was uh
itl and the last time it was retain
and so when you looked at it in the
fall uh this committee I believe voted
unanimously not to recommend future
legislation and here is the future
legislation so just saying that you've
had it you've done it it maybe it's time
to stop
it that's all thank you any questions
representative cier chairman now hasn't
remember when uh as I said in 2019 and
and 20 when the our committee passed a
bill that then Senator melan Lake
sponsored or an engineering project and
we got it through the house no it was a
Senate Bill I'm stand correct it was a
Senate bill it it was passed the Senate
came to the house this committee voted
it out we passed it on the house floor
and then the governor
uh just uh let it become law without his
signature then Governor sonunu so
something was started and some money I
think was appropriate for an engineering
study and I don't know if you can
comment on that and some of the data
that this study has uh uncovered so far
about how much it would cost a construct
passenger Rail between uh Manchester
Manchester and the mass
line uh I can't uh speak to that study
the the results of that study in a way
that I would be comfortable bringing
forth right today but I will say when
the final part of that study was stopped
because the executive Council didn't
appropriate the funds um you know again
if you a couple of people I think
representative voy has asked for data or
people have asked for data you can't
have the data to make your decision if
you
don't get the data and so to prohibit
the the continuation of a study which
would complete the data again I think is
not always good public
policy any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you Mr chair
I call
on Shelly Winters from the do please to
speak welcome back again to public
works so again for the record my name is
shelle Winters I'm the director of the
division of Aeronautics Rail and Transit
at the Department of
Transportation um and here to oppose
again I'm not here to advocate for the
New Hampshire Capital Corridor project
which has been bandied about just
looking at the wording of the bill um
we're really here to express a concern
about leaving future options open and
also point out a concern which is
brought up by some others that testified
on the committee about the specific
wording using passenger rail the title
again is clear says new when you get
into the text of um the bill it does not
use the term new and it converts from
using commuter rail down to passenger
rail that's been a question we've had
had as a department the last three times
this has been brought forward is what is
the definition of Passenger rail that
could that be construed to include the
existing um Amtrak Services both stop
with the stoping Claremont on the
Vermont on the vermonter and then the
down Easter on do D do um Durham and
exitor Does it include the Cog Railway
Does it include Conway Scenic who is
here to testify before that bring a lot
of tourist um business into the state so
again our concerns are about um the
wording in line nine with passenger Rail
and what that definition means and again
tying our future selves and what is what
do state funds really mean because as
was brought up before the Cog and other
railroads have accessed a revolving um
railroad fund that's established under
statute as under 228 66a the state has a
revolving rail railroad fund where the
state bonds and the railroads pay back
over a 20 or 30-year period for the
Investments that they make in in Rail
lines and a lot of those are supporting
um passeng passenger related um services
and also the state has a special
railroad fund which is EST established
under statute um
22868 it's a non-aps fund funds that uh
are derived from the use of state-owned
railroad properties are put into this
restricted account and then reinvested
by the department and again some of
those tenant railroads that use our
railroad lines are providing passenger
related Services again not commuter but
passenger related so um just I think we
wanted to to focus on the wording and
the intentionality of of the wording
right now seems to be a little bit
broader and that's been our testimony in
the past as well we currently have
nothing in the 10-year plan as was
mentioned by representative Jack the um
the last iteration of project 40818 came
to an early conclusion in Winter of 2023
we pulled that project number out of um
an earlier 10-year plan there's nothing
in our current 10-year plan relative to
anything that would be by Any Other Name
construed to mean a Commuter Rail
Project between Massachusetts tasa
Manchester or conquer so just wanted to
provide that Clarity that we currently
have nothing in our 10-year plan
relative to the project with with the
most attention here
today any questions for Miss Winters
representative Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you uh can you just
clarify the the study that was stopped
and Po and is posted on the website does
it have the completed financial plan or
did they need to do more work on that I
had heard at one point the additional
work they wanted to do was the new
starts application
only so the financial plan that is
posted on our website is based on a 30%
design level so um had we continued the
design uh would have likely escalated
that was also in the time period that
PanAm was being acquired by CSX so
additional conversations would have been
had with CSX and with the MBTA to to
talk about um additional needed
improvements so um it's final based on
the engineering done at the time and
making some inferences
so further questions representative
cluder okay thank you Mr chairman again
a 37 a 30% what is that again I'm sorry
level I'm didn't get that design level
design level thank you and a followup
please followup would this bill as
written ban future funding for
improvements to such tourist as a Cog
Railway and other legislations as you
read it as it's written now I think
that's our concern with the wording
saying passenger Rail and note State
funds without further Clarity to State
funds being defined or passenger rail
being defined there's a concern about
the uh the broad application of that yes
thank
you any further questions for Miss
Winters representative alone thank you
Mr chair I'm just going to follow up on
that um mentioned earlier uh wur article
about $1.2 million loan that was given
to the Cog Railway are you familiar with
that from that was done in the 20121 the
dollar amount escapes me but the Cog
rail Lo has applied and been a recipient
of railroad revolving loan funds through
the department correct follow followup
there was also
$160,000 that was uh awarded uh for
other projects were you aware of that or
something is that that fund that you
were talking about that revolving fund
that's the railroad revolving Loan Fund
is restricted to um certain
classifications of railroads the only uh
recipient in the last few years the last
few rounds has been the Cog Railway in
the past it has been Plymouth and
Lincoln Railroad and others but um I
would have to to check on the other 160
,000 you talk about it could be from a
different Source it's not ringing a bell
it's usually a much higher amount
through
us thank you thank you thank you any
other further questions for Miss
Winters M represented of rockmore thank
you Mr chairman so these loans from the
revolving railroad funds are they below
market rate or market rate I'm not aware
of the treasury um we send them the
information they look at what the
balance is in this revolving Loan
account and then they work just like
they do through all the other um bonded
it is lower rate that we offer than they
can get privately that's why it was
established and that's why we still
receive applications but I'm not sure
what the rate is that the the state gets
when we go through that Bond issuance
thank
you other questions seeing none I just
want to point out that Miss Winter's
brought as her backup here repres F I'm
sorry
Steve lebante
and Kathy M Sam Samson for from do who
bring with them a wealth of information
on this should we have had any
questions seeing no further questions
and it being
12:25 I'm going to hereby adjourn the
public hearing for House Bill 100
adjourned
here
represent I just
wanted I recognize that we don't engage
in debate with Witnesses and I've tried
to resist that attemptation but I do
want to point out that we do have a lot
of expertise on this board with with
the e